Hi, I'm David Washington and I'm a program manager on the Windows 8 user experience team.
I work on how Windows scale through different screens and form factors.
Today, I'm going to show you portrait and rotation on this Samsung prototype device.
Windows 8 tablets can be rotated at any time to the portrait view.
While on portrait you can check the weather,...
...switch back to that game that you're playing,...
...or read one of your favorite websites online.
Each application can tailor the view for what makes the most sense in portrait.
The great news is all the system controls work just as well in portrait, like the keyboard.
You can pick files from your file system...
...or you can use any of the system charms, like Share or Search.
And it works just as well in portrait as it does in landscape.
We hope you've enjoyed this quick demonstration of portrait and rotation in Windows 8.
We look forward to you trying it out yourself.